how about that view huh
that is the great pyramid of egypt and
here i am this is the view from my room
i can't believe it i'm pinching myself
it's surreal that i'm finally here
i've been wanting to come to egypt for
years and now i'm finally here
uh and it's been amazing so far i got
here so right now it's sunday morning
egypt time the sun just rose about a
half hour ago and i got here
thursday evening so for the last two
days i've been exploring the
giza plateau with my buddy ben and a few
other guys that came early
and this place has exceeded my
expectations which is saying something
because i
already had high expectations because i
already knew that there's
something very very special about egypt
he goes far beyond what most people
realize and
okay so hold on that is the great
pyramid of giza let's see if i can zoom
it all
nope that is a
the size of a 47 story building
closer to 500 feet tall this is not
doing it justice because i'm looking at
the camera and i'm looking at this
yeah it's like twice as big in my view
and it's really really close it's about
500 meters away you can walk there in
less than 10 minutes
and guys i have been
so here's the thing i've taken more than
2 000 photos
on my camera in the last two days and
that doesn't include videos and that
doesn't include everything i've taken on
my cell phone that i'm using right
now shooting this on the iphone 12 pro
if you're curious
i recommend this camera guys yesterday i
went inside the second pyramid
the pyramid of coffrey allegedly it's
not really that
it's not his pyramid let's be real and
holy
[ __ ] so first of all cameras are not
allowed in there but
if you give turns out money in this
world will get you things that you
wouldn't get otherwise if you guys
haven't figured that out yet
and oh my god did i get some videos and
some pictures
i can't i was like almost i was
speechless
it exceeded
guys what do you see i already have
numerous video ideas to come from the
things that i've seen in the last couple
days
things that i never even knew existed it
is unreal how much there is to see here
and how impressive it is
and i'm gonna i was talking to ben from
uncharted x of course you know ben
go follow him if you're not already and
uh because this is
his story he's putting on and the
wonderful people with the kevin school
of mysticism with yusuf ayan and
guys like this is absolutely
insane just how much there is to see and
just how
it's nuts i think i lost my train of
thought uh i'm on a few hours of sleep
this is what's so funny so i've been
jet-lagged but i'm not complaining
i've been uh in the last four days i
think i've gotten probably 15 or 16
hours of sleep
but yet i'm so awake like i can't it's
hard to sleep it's just so much to do
and where do i even begin i was gonna
make you guys a vlog
talking about my travels and what it
took to get here which was not easy
but like now that i'm here and i've been
like going in head first into everything
like
who cares about that flight who cares
about connecting in germany i mean all
that was interesting there's plenty of
stuff to chat about with that but
i'm in egypt now and i'm so blessed guys
starting this youtube channel i
i got off the couch i had a job i didn't
like
i chose to go back to school to get a
graduate degree thinking it's going to
bring me
a cushy desk job and make a bunch of
money only to realize that
it was the path to unhappiness
and there i was sitting on the couch and
i've always been into the egyptians
since in sixth grade when we learned
about it in school it was like that one
topic that
kept me focused whereas like math class
i'm like
looking around the room atd kicking in
and um
but with the egyptians i've always
thought it was amazing and
i was on the couches 2015 and i was not
particularly happy in life
i felt like there was i was just off my
path and there was more to it and there
i was just on the internet
looking at videos on youtube and i came
across a video of yusuf ayan and brian
forrester
um and they were at the sarah pm looking
at the 100 ton
or 70 plus ton 100 ton stone boxes which
we're gonna go see today
so there i was i sat up on my couch and
i was looking at this i'm like how have
i never seen
or heard of this stuff before and and
the mystery behind it that even the
egyptian antiquities department admits
they have no idea how that stuff was
made
so it's funny how it's come full circle
that here i am now
making a video looking at the pyramid
for my hotel room
i feel so blessed and so fortunate and
it's because of all of you
even watching my videos guys i make
money from the ad revenue
so you watching a video has helped me
get here all my patreon supporters
everyone all the good vibes you guys are
wonderful
and my point about getting off the couch
anything you want to do in life you can
do the law of attraction works if you if
you focus on good things
positive attitude gratitude and focusing
attention on
doing something and tip take actional
steps in that direction it will
materialize
it um it's real and so when i say i'm
pinching myself here i'm like
seeing is believing i envisioned this in
my mind and some people think that's all
woo-woo well guys woohoo is real
but even if you don't want to think of
it as just think of it as the power of
the human mind and making things happen
for yourself we all have choices
we have free will the world is operating
in a way that makes people think
otherwise
but that's not the case we're far more
powerful
let me let me stop rambling on that so
we're gonna go see a bunch of stuff
today
the last couple days um like i said i've
taken a few thousand photos
and there's a lot more to come um i
don't even know where to begin there's
just so much like the stuff i saw
hold on arm's getting tired the stuff i
saw today or excuse me yesterday and the
day before
exceeded my expectations like i said
there's things on the gisa plateau we're
talking like these 120 plus ton
limestone cut rocks that are right on
the causeway leading up to the uh
second pyramid and like it's just stuff
i've never even
seen or heard of before that is unreal
so
anyway i'm all over the place i'm
rambling we're all meeting uh
let me back up last night the tour
officially kicked off with the
introductory dinner
and wow what a great so there's 33 of us
including ben and myself
and what a wonderful group of people
such good vibes people from all over the
world we have people from
mostly from the united states but from
canada england denmark the netherlands
czechoslovakia
even people that originated in egypt all
over the place
and it's so it's amazing because
everyone's on the same wavelength
besides the fact that everyone here is
into the ancient egyptians
we're all traveling in november of 2020
which i don't know if you've noticed
things are a little nuts and people have
been cooped up in the house the whole
world is
guys rolling this together jesus like
this world is upside down
and it's so refreshing to be linking up
with other like-minded people that are
in the same boat that it's like you know
get busy living get busy dying let's go
see this stuff life is short
so i just have an overwhelming feeling
of gratitude like
thank you universe that i'm here and
thank you to everyone that supported me
uh i haven't even gone through all the
comments from my last photo just because
i've been
so freaking busy but everything that
i've seen so far
you guys are it warms my heart and i'm
beyond grateful
so just thank you so take in that view
pictures are not doing it justice look
how small that looks guys when you get
up close to it
and you see how big these freaking
stones are at its base you're like what
it's so deceiving you'll be getting
close to the pyramid and you'll think
you're closer than you are
and you keep walking and walking and
walking and walking
and you're still not getting closer to
it it's like it is
freaking huge and that is 203 levels
or stacks of blocks so take it all in
anyways guys i'm gonna be posting a lot
more i took
a i took an entire video tour of the
second pyramid
so i should just upload that it's like a
four or five minute video but uh
um maybe i'll save it for one of my
videos when i get back i don't know i
have to pick and choose what i'm gonna
send to instagram i'm just gonna start
dumping things on here to keep you guys
posted but
i'm gonna wrap this up um
i'm gonna go finish some coffee and make
a meet up with my tour group
and uh i guess i'll just leave it at
that
love all bye